hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you
that wasn't a bad one i'm just maybe
it's because i'm in a great [ __ ] mood
and i don't even know why
that was it because i went out i did a
little bit of stand-up last night i had
a great [ __ ] time
i had a great time you know i had a
hissy fit at the [ __ ] comedy store i
walked in i was trying to knock out a
show early i come walking in i'm like
you know they got a show going on can i
jump on just 10 minutes 10 minutes i'll
get it out get out of the way hey try to
be a [ __ ] problem right
i go yeah and i go walking in the main
room and then they got like cameras on
and i'm like oh jesus christ what the
[ __ ] is this
and uh they were like oh we're live
streaming it i go jesus [ __ ] christ
can't you just do a [ __ ] show
does everything have to be viewed can i
come down here and work out my john
gruden bit right
so
you know i flip on they go no no it's
lives i felt bad it's my buddy mustafa
from a long time i gotta apologize to
the guy i was just like i mean i'd say
anything to him i just was like i'm so
[ __ ] these [ __ ] goddamn kids
filming every [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ]
moment
there's just cameras in the locker room
now you know so
somebody over there was like no it's
live stream you can't film it's like yes
you can you just take your cell phone
and you point it at the [ __ ] screen
so i just you know whatever i just so i
i leave in a big huff big huff acting
like a [ __ ] hollywood starlet the
1950s right
oh billy oh billy apologies you know i
walk into a place next thing you know i
owe three people an apology cause that's
how i'm [ __ ] wired so and that will
happen
not saying i'm not an [ __ ] but then i
i just like i'm so [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i just said [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] way
out
because i didn't get what i want i mean
i can't believe i showed up without
calling anybody and expected everything
was gonna go my way i mean why why
wouldn't that happen
[ __ ] idiot i am anyway so
then i go down to the improv and they
got a couple of shows going on there
and uh
i go on
in the side room
and it's like the gay show or something
like that so then the john gruden thing
became fun because he said homophobic
[ __ ] right so i was like you know
you know i whatever i did what i usually
do right
and then i don't know
i got to try out my bit about straight
people that collect gay people as
friends
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] killed it's funny it
wouldn't kill in front of like a bunch
of straight progressive people
because they would get offended for the
people that you know let me know i was
saying it in the right way and then the
main room
there was some sort of adult
entertainment
vibe to it either the stand-ups used to
be an adult entertainment or the people
in the crowd was them i don't know
everything's like a [ __ ] theme now
you know oh this is like just to let you
know before you go up
this is the car wash union everybody
here washes cars a lot of people aren't
legal they're trying to get their
families into the area of the car wash
just be sensitive
if you have any jokes about water i'm
not saying you can't do them i would
just be careful
um
yeah so
i didn't even look up that whole john
gruden thing i don't even see what the
[ __ ] happened he got a bunch of emails
and all of that [ __ ] but the vibe i'm
hearing is that they're using
you know as the nfl always does they use
like acting like they care about other
people really to just get rid of some
guy
uh john gruden
calls
goodell
a [ __ ] because you know that that was
the one
greatest jungle to resign amid criticism
over misogynistic and homophobic emails
it sounds like he called somebody a
[ __ ] and then he said use the f word
um
oh jesus christ
i'm not getting into this i'm not
[ __ ] reading this i'll read this
later i'll have something new to talk
about in atlanta
i'm going to
i'm going going back back to atlanta
atlanta
um doing a couple nights out there
thursday friday say
i got a couple of friends of mine who
live out that way they're gonna pop on
do some guest spots it's gonna be fun
oh billy fat tits got on the scale my
scale sucks not only does it suck
because i don't like the number it's
giving me but like it literally you move
it on the floor and it'll go three
pounds
in either direction so i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm weighing but i'm i'm not
liking it i'm in hoodie shape right now
and um
you know i just got like as always i
have like nine million [ __ ] things
going on and i just can't get my [ __ ]
ass
back into the shape i need to be in but
it's gonna now the holidays are coming
up i mean i'm done
i'm looking at a heart attack in [ __ ]
january i don't knock this off
um but anyway i called up one of my
favorite shows you can listen to it
tomorrow
uh the shredding reagan show
buffalo and those guys have been having
me on the radio
since i played like the [ __ ]
the town ballroom
way back in the day in buffalo which by
the way
is was such a cool place to play
because uh
downstairs in the basement they had
um
like these tunnels that were bricked
over and that's where all the
prohibition gangsters used they would
run down those [ __ ] tunnels when the
cops would come in to bust them
so they wouldn't get arrested obviously
and uh
lately i've been watching you know been
binge watching the whole [ __ ]
untouchable series with robert stack
and all of those guys walter winchell
and um
just seeing a whole show about that era
and just thinking about that place so
anyways i'm gonna be coming back there
and uh you can listen to that tomorrow i
have to have a couple of things uh
i think to promote
but i didn't write them down before i
got on here i'm the [ __ ] worse
so now i gotta check my god damn
i'll tell my wife [ __ ] [ __ ] yelled
at me this morning
she [ __ ] you know she was like she
didn't consider it yelling i gotta get
her on the podcast
she doesn't consider it yelling
which is funny to me it's like well if i
did that
it would be considered yelling
um
oh here's the thing that i was supposed
to pro i'm supposed to promote here
a friend of mine um unfortunately
his
nephew uh committed suicide sorry to bum
everybody out here but uh there's a
gofundme
um
it's weird it says go fund me
and then i don't am i supposed to
retweet this
um
i don't know i'll retweet it i'll figure
it out now that i brought that up and
brought the whole [ __ ] room down
brought the whole goddamn room down um
anyway
why would i do that you either do that
at the top or you do it you do it at the
end that's where you do that
now that i've made you laugh here's
something sad but you can make a
positive out of it that's it bing bang
boom that's how i should have done it
oh by the way you know what really
[ __ ] annoyed me about the john gruden
thing
was somebody [ __ ]
posted this thing going uh classic
mediocre white male
you know he his his overall record is
under 500
and he gets a 100 million contract it's
just like i swear to god everybody use
their own 24-hour news channel where
they just [ __ ]
they just they just frame it the way
they want to frame it
my favorite thing too was it was
retweeted by a white female
which goes back to that bit i did
a while back how white women have
divorced themselves of their own [ __ ]
privilege
um they're not mediocre they're
extraordinary
oh the level that they're performing at
my god
if they were a white male they'd be
running the planet
[ __ ] ridiculous so anyway it's like
first of all you dumb [ __ ]
you sexist
racist [ __ ] all right i'm not defending
what the guy obviously shouldn't be
saying
uh racist stuff you shouldn't be saying
uh you know uh homophobic things the
misogyny i have no problem with if you
listen to this podcast i mean i've
that's i've basically
hung my shingle on that i'm [ __ ] with
you i have issues with women all right
i'm working hey i'm working on it okay
um
the way that they [ __ ] framed that
okay you want to say that he shouldn't
have said that abso-fucking-lutely
absolutely i understand that but to act
like this guy is a mediocre coach
is not the case he's one of the best
coaches of his generation he took over
the raiders twice
when they were a pile of ashes
that's like that mcdermott guy uh um
with [ __ ] buffalo
right i bet he doesn't have a 500 record
look what he's done with buffalo they
well they were laying in the gutter
people stepping over him
bills fans dropping half-eaten wings on
top of their [ __ ] heads by october
every [ __ ] year
and he pee dug down deep he plowed
through it and now look at him
dare i say in the driver's seat
and the afc
granted tom brady went to the nfc you
know
that kind of helps him
um
yeah john gruden he's [ __ ] the guy
won a super bowl they don't bring that
up
right maybe he's like oh we did it with
tony dungy's team well great good for
who the [ __ ] tony dungy tony dungy
won with the colts he also played by the
way he played his own uh uh green went
up against his own [ __ ] raiders team
so he played his own [ __ ] team even
leaving his team still got there he
doesn't get credit for that he gets a
super bowl they said oh that's cause
[ __ ] tony junjie's team tony dungy
won a [ __ ] super bowl when [ __ ]
jim irsay made how the patriots covered
their receiver illegal and then they
stole our offense
so
you can say what i want about the guy
socially
but don't come after this football
record if you're not a [ __ ] football
person especially
if you're just some white lady walking
around you're [ __ ] living your white
life
i just cannot [ __ ] believe that white
women have the [ __ ] nerve to sit
there go classic media over a [ __ ]
white male like they're [ __ ] like
what are you you got to crush it as hard
as james brown
the [ __ ] out of here
how many ladies nights did you go to we
didn't have to pay a cover and somebody
bought you a [ __ ] drink the level of
whining it's i'll never get women of
color i will listen to all [ __ ] day
long but though i always make sure
that i remind
those white ladies
that you're riding in the same chariot
i'm riding
okay maybe you're not always telling the
horse which way it wants to go
you know but that's why you're trying to
lock us in to give you the ring
then all of a sudden you know you're
telling the horse which way to go it
becomes your horse and your [ __ ]
carriage and if you don't like it you
kick us out of the carriage you get to
keep the carriage because you're used to
a certain horse lifestyle and i'm
walking down the street paying for your
[ __ ] notes
all right sorry
um
so there you go now all of that
i haven't read a [ __ ] word of any of
his emails
you know i'm not a soap opera guy
[Music]
i don't watch pregame i don't watch
[ __ ] post game i don't give a [ __ ] if
somebody on the [ __ ] washington
wizards
you know brings a goddamn gun into the
[ __ ] uh clubhouse because he's mad
about a card game i don't give a [ __ ]
work that out amongst yourselves the
only thing i care about in that [ __ ]
story
is the irony that you called them the
wizards and they still brought a gun
into the [ __ ] locker room they should
still be called the bullets
all right
the sacramento king should still be the
buffalo braves is that who the [ __ ] they
were the buffalo uh who the [ __ ] were
they
oh man i used to know all that sports
history it's leaving me
you know
what a [ __ ] great move that was
for whatever what what [ __ ]
basketball team
was in not the bisons they had all kinds
of [ __ ] they're all they're all about
the goddamn meat up there
there's not a vegetarian is there a
vegetarian restaurant in buffalo
i mean that would be something else
i mean one of the hardest things to do
is to put your money into a restaurant
and think that you're not going to lose
your [ __ ] shirt you start opening a
vegan restaurant now you know what's
going to happen actually bill you'd be
surprised there's a whole new vibrant
downtown area
you know all these [ __ ]
app makers and web designers they're
bringing back the rust belt i don't get
mad at that at least you know it's good
americans are working again but jesus
you know
it's a lot more fun to hang out with the
other guys back in the day oh bill oh
billy lamenting
the [ __ ] was i just looking up
nba
buffalo
the buffalo braves
the buffalo are they now then they
became the kansas city kings and then
the [ __ ] uh sacramento kings is that
what it is buffalo braves
and
nba
history
history all right they played in the
buffalo memorial auditorium the buffalo
braves
what are they now
buffalo braves
who's that big guy bob lanier right is
that who the [ __ ] it was
okay okay the plays began they were
there blah blah blah initial hiring
where did they move to 74 bob mcadoo
um most valuable player award 77-78 team
team colors
all right where are they where are they
for the franchise first season
uh where the another's talking colors
all right let me look up the sacramento
kings sacramento
kings let's see what the [ __ ] they are
now
sacramento kings oh they were the
rochester royals is that what it was
rochester seagram's rochester dead the
pros the royals then the cincinnati
royals the kansas city kings
kansas city kings all right so
are they the golden state warriors
ah jesus christ who uh this is why i
don't know what's going on in the world
because i will [ __ ] sit here till i
figure this out but i will not even know
what john gruden said who are
where
do the buffalo
braves play today
there's one sports not listening to this
where are the buffalo braves now
1978 he swapped the franchise
with then owner barcelona who moved the
team to san diego they became the
clippers the san diego clippers now
they're the la clippers jesus christ no
wonder they never won anything
they got that buffalo stink on him dude
buffalo has to win a [ __ ]
championship
you know
the way liberals were like we have to
get donald trump out of office anything
is better how about a 90 year old guy
with dementia should he have his finger
on the red button that sounds fantastic
um
he's also a warmonger even better is
this ty blue fantastic
i'm a
i'm a liberal i don't see color unless
it's ties
all right um
you know not to say that you know donald
trump is a gut guy it's just [ __ ]
horrible he's a monster
um
anyway um i don't like any of them
i don't like
and you know what's funny about this
[ __ ] is if you talk to your grandparents
and you hear the [ __ ] that comes out of
their mouth
because of when they grew up why the
[ __ ] would you want that like leading
your country i mean how many [ __ ]
generations behind
are the last two
presidents i mean it's pretty [ __ ]
awful
i mean they basically were picking from
the cast of cocoon over there
who's gonna come next is walter mondale
still alive no he passed away
oh you know who's gonna [ __ ] run that
i bet jerry brown jerry
um
anyway buffalo
they need
to win
a championship
i mean right now what do they have
what do they have
okay you have
like the end of the buffalo sabres was
when milan lucich ran ryan miller and
the sabres did nothing about it
okay
they packed it in they quit
just like all those steel factories and
they left and they went to some
god-forsaken place
you know where coca-cola has real sugar
in it right that's where they went
um
all the [ __ ] buffalo bills fans have
right now
it's a parking lot
full of men
who don't know how to talk to women
so they try to get attention
by jumping off of a car and breaking a
table
i'm just [ __ ] with you i actually
like that they do that i'm an old school
wrestling fan
you know
the best ones
aren't the ones where they miss the
table i like when they hit the table and
it doesn't break
and then their body bends in a way that
you never thought a human body could
bend you know
if you took a picture of him it would
look like they melted like you had him
frozen and then they just sort of melted
and that that half that's hanging over
just [ __ ] breaks in half
um oh when i see them doing that it
really miss i really makes me miss
boozing
you know
just not facing who i am as a person
burying emotions
and taking it out on other people i just
and not really remembering it i really
miss oh wait a minute i did that last
night at a comedy club
well and now i just have hissy fits
i used to be belligerent now i'm just
like it's [ __ ] scary okay just
[ __ ] too sad
well bill you could have called ahead i
don't blame the victim i really was
billy hollywood last night
um
so anyway
yeah so i did those two shows last night
and then what's great there's a little
cigar bar right next to the
improv and i bought one of my favorite
[ __ ] cigars it's just one of those
little nubs
i can never remember the name of it
it's not
hubano what the [ __ ] is it
what the [ __ ] what is it
i also like it because it gets right to
the point it's a nice gauge bing bang
boom
remember this guy gave me [ __ ] for
smoking those going you know i think
you'd like you know a higher level of
tobacco it's like dude you smoke like
four a day you're a [ __ ] animal
you know how dare you
that's like a [ __ ] alcoholic who's
drinking out of a [ __ ] jug
you know we're sitting there judging the
level of booze that you're going after
it's like why don't you just [ __ ]
deal with whatever the [ __ ] happened to
you and your childhood and i'll be over
here doing the same
yeah the habano
that's the one
that billy loves
he's doing so well this month too
all right i'll get back on it because
i'm not gonna smoke when i'm in well
maybe i will
kind of already been invited out nah
what do you want from me all righty it's
thompson cigars everybody uh ad-lib what
you love about smoking cigars i just
love sitting by myself
and not thinking
you know having a little root beer
sitting on my back porch
i love the company i love cigars you
know sometimes i want to be hanging with
somebody i love cigar smokers i love
cigar lounges i love all things
cigar
so
i got to tell you something that's why i
got to check out thompson cigar whether
you're working from home or just kicking
back after a week of being essential
there's no better way to relax than with
a premium cigar with over a century in
the business these guys really know
their stuff they got the best prices on
the biggest brands in the business from
mackinuto to monte cristo
uh looking to try some rare top rated
blends but don't want to splurge on
boxes you know because what if you don't
like them then you're stuck with the box
well check out thompson's cigar tour a
smattering of five different blends
delivered to your doorstep each month
and thomas's five-pack fever that's a
great way to learn about cigars too you
got a five different one each month you
know all of a sudden you know where your
pallets at you can build your little
[ __ ] uh little uh box of goodies
there
um in thompson's five pack fever program
they had the largest selections of
samplers online with the options to
build your own or choose from over 300
different five pack options to mix and
match they also send out insane cigar
deals with personalized emails
preference options options so you can
sign up to receive them all or just the
days you feel like reading emails uh
thompson cigar company continues to be
the number one choice for premium cigars
in the usa because they deliver the best
customer experience all right
um all right i love the sample packs i
like the ones that got the my fathers i
love a couple of nubs i love the auroras
um
i love them all uh so sit back and take
a picasa magnus sit back and take a
break from all the craziness with the
cigar from thompson cigar company these
guys really do offers but right now
thompson is offering our listeners 15
off orders over 75 or 20 off over uh
orders over 99 this is great for the
holidays too you know get some cigars
hang out with your friends or get some
for your old man to take advantage of
these incredible savings simply go to
thompsoncigar.com and use the promo code
burr when you're ready to check out that
website is thompson
t-h-o-m-p-s-o-n-cigar.com and use the
promo code burr oh look who it is
do me undies me undies watch what you
say in email do do do do me undies be
undies or your career will [ __ ] set
sail
and you'll no longer be the head of the
ship
you send you out the door you're a
[ __ ] dripper your career is over and
the money's probably not guaranteed if
you called a commissioner a [ __ ] oh by
the way we care about blacks and
gay people
where the [ __ ] nfl yeah me undies uh
are you afraid of the glow in the dark
well shield your eyes because the new
meundies halloween just dropped dead
if there's one collection you don't want
a ghost it's this one oh jesus with five
new prints to turn up the terror you
should summon them before it's too late
whether you're out running a killer or
being abducted by aliens this halloween
be comforted by the fact that your
undies are sustainable and the softest
in town meundies are made from natural
fibers sourced from beechwood trees
making their micro modal modal fabric
soft and breathable and dangerously cozy
get your spooky season up and hunting
and haunting with five new prints
uh i see you eye my boo
tricks in treats
lazy bones
and lazy pumpkin available in undies
bralettes socks and loungewear and sizes
xs through 4xl there are a lot of
options to consider but make a decision
quickly because there's something
there's somebody right behind you
uh me undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15 off and free shipping myani's
also promises if you're not satisfied
with any product for any reason you can
return your order for a full refund
within 45 days to get 15 off your first
order free shipping and 100 satisfaction
guarantee go to
meundies.com
that's meundies m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s
dot com slash bur b-u-r-r
you know what's annoying is the lack of
drum sheet music and then trying to
actually [ __ ] download the [ __ ]
sometimes like sometimes i just like
seeing like uh when things just have
like uh
a weird time
and i can't figure out like i can count
it but i can't figure out how somebody
if they wrote it in sheet music would
figure it out like let's say oh i don't
know let's say uh
iron maiden numbered the beast
right i could always play along with the
guitar riff i never knew it wasn't in
four until the other day i tried to
finally count it i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on here
and it was it was it's one two three
four one two three four one two and then
back into it again and i i was sitting
there going is this like uh
is this in five
you know because that comes out to ten
i'm like no
whether where one is that's not working
out
and i just couldn't figure it out and
then i couldn't figure out that
[Music]
that part there and that that bad part
is on one and it's one two three four
one two three four and then it's that
that is one two three it's a line of
three two bars of four one bar a three
and i've never been able to figure that
out and now just because i can see it on
paper and i can count it i can now play
it
um i like that [ __ ] so you go online
and they'll have it written out and then
you try to like take a screenshot of it
and they pixelate it like all right i
get it okay so i'll pay a couple bucks
for this [ __ ] thing
and i can't figure it out
you know
i got to create an account and all of
that [ __ ] and it's just like why don't
you just put this in a [ __ ] book and
i'll buy it for like 20 bucks
instead of selling me one song in a
[ __ ] time
oh my god these [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry anyway um
but uh i've been flying like a [ __ ]
lunatic
i've flown every single day this month
except for one
flying the best i've ever flown and uh i
wish i could take video of you guys
watching me shooting these approaches
the gps ones are easy because you don't
have to do anything
it does everything for you
um because when you get to your final
approach fix
all right it's tune twist
what what is it i [ __ ]
toon twist turn that's right tune twist
turn throttle talk touch
all right you're tuned to the profit
frequency
on a vo it's on a vor right
which is a an older i guess technology
as gps is taking over so in that one you
have to tune to the vor which is like a
radio antenna on the ground
okay so you're flying the right radio
then you have to time it your category a
if you fly under 90 knots like i do with
my little egg beater
and then i know if i just keep it at 80
knots getting from the final a pitch uh
approach fix to the uh missed approach
point
is going to take four minutes
right
at that point you don't see the [ __ ]
runway
you know
you [ __ ] take off i think that's what
it is or whatever you're allowed to go
to a certain altitude down to a certain
level and then fly that altitude t get
to the missed approach point where on
gps once you get to the decision
altitude if you don't see it then you
have to [ __ ] immediately take off
sorry
just trying to keep all of this in my
[ __ ] head
so i was doing one the other day
when you get to the final approach
um
fix
i had to like
tune
time and then twist because the course
changed from zero seven nine to like
zero four six
throttle talk didn't need to touch
because i was already in the vor thing
and i am like i had the whole thing
like how it works learning this [ __ ] is
the first thing is you just learn how to
track radials so then you get that done
so then you're good to get to the first
approach fix and then you [ __ ]
everything after that and then after a
while you get good
all the way now i'm all i can do the
whole [ __ ] thing right to that point
and on the [ __ ] the vor once it just
all falls apart and i'm going too fast
and i'm literally in the aircraft going
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ]
[Music]
my instructor's just laughing at me he
goes no no you're doing fine everybody
goes through this am i coming up [ __ ]
long do i gotta fly these [ __ ] things
i gotta go to atlanta this weekend by
the time i figure this [ __ ] [ __ ] out
i gotta [ __ ] leave again
as i'm flying with like a [ __ ]
basically like blinders on like a horse
obviously he's looking out for traffic
but i have to i will tell you this even
if i [ __ ] fail this thing and it
doesn't work out because this is a
[ __ ]
this is for me okay you know i'm not the
brightest guy i'm not the best speller i
do have like a touch of [ __ ] i don't
know what 80d i got a little bit of
dyslexia and i got a lot of [ __ ]
emotional problems um this has been one
of the hardest [ __ ] things
i've ever done yet fascinating
i am now totally fascinated with like uh
the ifr charts which i never looked at
and this is why aviation is so [ __ ]
annoying
if you're on like a just a regular vfr
chart if that's what the [ __ ] you call
it visual flight rules
like a charlie airport class charlie is
magenta
then you go to ifr and now it's [ __ ]
blue and it's like blue is bravo
and then bravo the area is still blue as
far as i could tell the ifr and it's
just like it's like the left hand
doesn't know what the [ __ ] right
hand's doing why wouldn't it always be
magenta
i know this makes sense to make [ __ ]
two percent of the people but i just
don't understand
why they don't do that so i don't know
but anyway so this morning that's what i
was doing i was like loading instrument
approaches because i have to know what
everything you know
on the uh
what do they call that that part of a
map where it tells you what all the
symbols mean
that [ __ ] word that just made me
think back in the day like i'm not
passing this i'm not passing this test
what was it called the magellan
what are they what are they what is that
[ __ ] map word
oh god it's gonna escape me i'll [ __ ]
the second i
stop this podcast i'll immediately
remember it but anyway
um that is the podcast hockey season's
coming up baby
hockey's coming back oh wait a second
wait oh my god i can't believe i didn't
bring it up how about those [ __ ] red
socks
right before i go i want to give a shout
out to all those [ __ ] yankees fans
when we beat you in the one game playoff
and you couldn't [ __ ] take it you all
all of your [ __ ] said oh have fun
getting owned by the devil race
i just want to let you know we had a lot
of fun getting owned by the devil race
we had a lot of goddamn fun
losing the first game and then winning
the next three
whoa
on to the next round
on to the next round yankees on the next
round a golf you [ __ ] striped [ __ ]
just kidding i respect the yankees i
just don't like that fan base i mean 27
championships okay i don't know if you
guys know this but the yankees have won
27 championships their fan base doesn't
have to bring that up every october now
when they lose
oh
shots
fired
speaking of fire that's what's gonna
happen to your gm oh
bam
so i don't know who we play next i'm
hoping we're gonna play the astros
and just have like the trash can off and
just see who bangs on the trash can that
it's all gonna come down to who got the
best trash can and [ __ ] it
all right that's it
uh go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check in on
you no this is thursday before we end
the podcast
uh we have my nfl chat of the week
with the honor one and only paul versi
here we go you can listen to our picks
for next week listen to them bet against
us keep score do whatever you want a
couple of meatheads talking football
here we go okay all right everybody
welcome back to another
weekly segment here of
of of of bet mgm
all right we're back for week six of the
anything better bet mgm nfl picks and
previews the hottest gambling show dare
i say
in podcasting history on a saturday in
october
in 2021 when you're watching this right
now uh you guys have been i guess
evidently according to the feedback paul
they've been having a lot of fun with
their picks
some of you made a lot of money picking
with of us picking with us paul verzi
some picking against us me
um if you haven't signed up for bet mgm
yet what are you waiting for use the
bonus code bur b-u-r-r
b-u-r-r
and you'll get 200 free after placing
your first bet your first 10 bet all
right here's how it works download the
bet mgm app and sign up using bonus code
bur burr place your first 10 money line
bet on any game
after you do that you'll receive 200
bucks
200 balloons paul in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome of your bet
you could lose that 10 bucks and still
get 200.
hey paul with my public school math that
says that right there says you're up 190
bucks just make sure you use the bonus
code bur burr when you sign up all right
now it is time to talk about last week's
picks
and go into this week's pick it's paul
versi continuing on his tear
his revenge you ever hear chicks they
have their revenge body
after somebody breaks up with them i
beat paul two years
in a row gambling and paul is back with
his revenge body betting
it's an early bill
paul that's not like you to not talk
[ __ ] are you okay you got a fever no
listen man it's only we got a fancy
[ __ ] sweatshirt on paul verse he goes
three and one again
taking bet mgm by the right hand
throwing it over his shoulder the next
week grabs it by the left and this guy
paul you never went three and one on
multiple choice in public schools i mean
you are just destroying as soon as i
talk [ __ ] i go 0-4 i'm not taking that
bait i'm just going be uh don't pull
your knees into your chest okay you've
been talking [ __ ] since i met you
uh
well yeah listen man um
i you know what's funny is i texted
andrew and i go dude i'm gonna do it i'm
going 4-0 i i talked about justin
herbert but didn't take the charges i
thought i did because i talked about
them but i took
the las vegas raiders and again and i'm
sticking to this i'm sticking to this
john gruden distraction urban meyer
distracted dude i tweeted i said i said
urban meyer owes john gruden a drink
[ __ ] everybody loved it
that's true
he took him right off the front page
dude my dumb ass i bet jacksonville
because i hated how you stated the
obvious
and i wanted it to not work
coach is out booze and he's not hanging
with the team i love this it's like it
was just so obvious to me i hated it i
hated how proud of yourself that you
were
like you were reading the tea leaves and
like an [ __ ] i bet against it i lost
i went one in three
the only people saving me
were the detroit lions let me tell you
something paul you know you're having a
bad week gambling when the only team
that saves you is the detroit lions the
detroit lions haven't saved anybody
since eisenhower was in office well we
have to discuss this because andrew and
i spoke about it i don't know that you
went one and three i think you might
have went one two and one and here's why
because in real betting when there's a
push you don't lose money
you don't i grew up ties lost paul
i don't know about your generation where
everyone gets a ribbon but if you want
to say on one two and one
no bet mgm
and any booker will tell you if the line
is seven and the game happens to be
seven that's what they call the old push
so i think i thought you you i got to
pay the juice or something right
no i don't i you know i thought hey you
know i'm not going to talk you out of it
you want to give me a tie i'll take a
tie
listen i think that's like kissing your
cousin i mean i either want to have my
head in my hands crying or you know
skipping across naked across my lawn no
because she's high i don't know what i'm
supposed to do with it no you
technically you technically didn't lose
money
so i think we go one two and one yeah i
did because that [ __ ] [ __ ] hit the
red piece of tape on top of the field
goal
[ __ ] jerk off is jumping up and down
like he just won me some money he was
yelling into the place kicker i had one
billboard money
i won billboard money and then bum bump
bomb
oh
what a day for kicking 11 missed extra
points [ __ ] field goals all [ __ ]
day
i felt bad for that kicker on the
bengals because i knew the second he
knew the second he jumped up and down
all those snarky [ __ ]
who can barely tie their shoe without
passing out we're all going to trash him
on sportscenter
i love when he jumped up he goes and
then he came down and he goes no you
know you looked around like no
hey paul we've all been there that's
what i don't like about making fun of
him people should be relating to him
rather than saying what a jackass i
agree well the amount of times that i
jumped into the arms of another man
thinking that i had done something
wonderful
and then found out that i didn't pau i
mean it's just off the charts
well who am i
to make fun of that poor bastard this is
what pissed me off the last couple years
everybody has been saying i look like
sean mcdermott the head coach of the
buffalo bills then all of a sudden the
bills start winning
nobody says i look like the guy anymore
right and then all of a sudden the fat
headed [ __ ] bald [ __ ] on the uh on
the texans
they try to do a fake punt paw
they fake a fake punt
they come up to the line they act like
the punt is under center and then to
draw in the returner
yeah so then he's gonna for some dumb
like that's gonna do anything so then
he's gonna run back and try and fake it
he didn't run back far enough
he goes to kick it and it's his own
player in the helmet for zero yards then
all of a sudden everybody starts saying
i look like that guy
because sean's winning all of a sudden
he has his own identity
oh that's fine i don't know who am i
paul who am i you know i'm just the guy
who keeps going one and three if he can
say anything i am consistent so i'm not
worried that i'm leaving gamblers astray
okay because at this point they know
that i'm going to pick four games and
three of them are going to be losers so
they should be able to pick a winner
from that
uh okay
paul let's get into week six
the picks this week and how much the
[ __ ] browns got [ __ ] over on those
goddamn pass interference calls which
cost me another victory but i'm over it
um week six do i go first you go first
uh it is your go you go odd i go well
i'm loving i'll tell you what i'm loving
right now i am loving the seattle
seahawks
uh
getting five in pittsburgh pittsburgh no
juju smith shuster big ben is hurt he's
been hurt his whole career but now he's
old so this might actually affect him i
usually feel big ben plays better at
home when he is hurt
it's that whole pittsburgh thing where
everybody in pittsburgh you know now
everybody under the age of 50 acts like
they used to work in a steel mill we all
know they didn't
they're all building apps and websites
and that type of [ __ ] but they try to
act like they're tough with their
[ __ ] hard hats and all of that
i say the seattle seahawks
with old sneaky pete without russell
without russell wilson now god damn it i
looked up the injury report and it said
nothing about that russell wilson isn't
in no gino smith
ah jesus christ what [ __ ] internet do
i have
it's said to be determined right [ __ ]
that i'm gonna go with the guys that
have been getting me there every week
i'm going with the buffalo bills no
minus five and a half going against the
tennessee titans i think the titans are
limited paul
i think uh you know they got an
incredible runner whatever the [ __ ] his
name is
uh that ryan tanner hill you know what i
mean you can have him you can have me
you can have that punter from [ __ ]
houston as far as i'm concerned i also
think that everybody kind of knows what
mike frable does
and they've slowed him down a little bit
i'm not saying he's not a good coach but
i think they figured something out
i think mike brabel needs to cross all
the t's and dot all the eyes and some
other sort of sports [ __ ] analogy
and my 1-3 money week after week i'm
taking the [ __ ]
buffalo bills dance with who brung you
paul
well you know what i got excited when
you said the seattle seahawks because i
would have had it a head-to-head i am
riding this pittsburgh steelers train to
victory again i think geno smith being
out but i also love what i saw in
roethlisberger last week and their home
and i think that the seattle seahawks
are gonna
you know expose geno smith i got that
game's got pick six written all over it
i'm taking the pittsburgh steelers minus
five at home to win two in a row and
right the ship all right i'll tell you
what game i'm staying away from i don't
like the broncos raiders as much as
[ __ ]
what's-his-face john gruden
just lost 100 million dollars because of
a couple of emails
and some choice words that the raiders
are gonna be fly i don't know it's a
division rivalry i hate that [ __ ]
game so what i'm gonna do what am i
gonna do paul
all freckles
what you gonna do
i'm gonna go with the kansas city chiefs
everybody start everybody's starting to
jump off their bandwagon
they're going you know maybe patrick
mahomes is is is is uh you know a
one-and-done guy after every time oh he
drew a no-look pass holy jesus christ
every [ __ ] thing that the guy did
i'm with the chiefs i think kelsey has a
big game i think he stomps all around
like he always does all over
washington's field i think thomas
jefferson is rolling over in his grave
by the third quarter i got the
i got the chiefs given seven
in washington i like that pick i i you
know my homes they've been talking a lot
of [ __ ] all right i'm gonna go
all right my second pick here
okay
my second pick here here we go
the green bay packers are in chicago do
i like that game
uh bet mgm's line has it at
a 4.5
um
the hapless lions have not won i don't
know what to do here but i think what
i'm gonna do
oh man i can't believe i'm doing this
i'm gonna take the los angeles chargers
i looked at that game getting three
against baltimore who's coming off of
one of the greatest games and
from a quarterback they baltimore is
home but justin herbert did something
against the the browns that i really
liked
i think he's gonna go in there i like
them getting points give me the chargers
for my second game give paul the charges
all right i gotta tell you something
paul
i gotta tell you something right now the
miami dolphins
who a lot of people don't
know oh what the [ __ ] i thought they
were in like the top ten with defenses
now wait a minute dude every website you
go to has something [ __ ] different
i thought the dolphins were like in the
top ten i i i don't like this pic
this is the battle of florida paul this
is the battle of two cities you don't
want to go to for two different reasons
miami all the cocaine and the botox
and jacksonville all the broken dreams
you know but who wants to go to tampa
if you don't have kids you're not going
to orlando you know what
uh
i thought i had all my picks here i'm
going to take the miami dolphins given
three and a half
yeah
okay they got the living [ __ ] kicked out
of him last week
by tom brady he came down there and he
squished the fish
and you know maybe uh you know maybe he
has maybe they have a problem paul i got
to be honest with you i'm floating here
nah dude she took my you took my pick
that's what i wanted that's what you get
for going first on even days i love it
[ __ ] you i gave you two chances to take
that and you didn't take it don't come
back at me and start crying like some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] whose dream didn't come true in
the business so now they got to tell
some story from 20 years ago it's
[ __ ] blame
something doesn't smell right in
jacksonville oh it's urban meyer's
finger okay
i'll give the guy a break
he went to a hooters he got a little
sideways
it happens you know your nose is running
from all of those [ __ ] hot wings
next thing you know some chick who has
no business being anywhere near you that
age so i mean he wasn't making a rubber
s on his dick was he
you know paul maybe he wanted to be
faithful and that's why that you know
sometimes you attract what you fear
maybe that's what happened paul
all right
well
why aren't these [ __ ] held accountable
this isn't
i don't like this week man this
cleveland browns cardinals game is
killing me because the line
the bed mgn line is perfect oh my god
the the browns are home after a brutal
win this really is my brutal loss
i mean brutal loss this really is my
homecoming theory and you know what the
cardinals haven't lost yet [ __ ] it i'm
taking
the cleveland brownies
giving the arizona cardinals their first
loss
minus three give me the give me the
browns
all right is this my last one
this is my last pick right andrew
i can't i'm not on the video page so i'm
not looking here uh yes okay all right
all right it's my last one paul
all right i'll tell you right now i paul
your giants are at home getting
disrespected
they're getting nine and a half points
at home paul they're walking into your
house
and they're getting a free appetizer and
a [ __ ] plate of pasta
but i just don't believe in them
i do not [ __ ] believe in them so i
you know what paul just to make it
interesting
i'm going to take the arizona cardinals
because they haven't done me wrong yet
they got jj watts they got chandler
jones i think they're going to be in
baker mayfield's face i think he's tired
from all of those [ __ ] commercials i
think he runs all around and i think
what happens in cleveland for the last
[ __ ] 50 60 [ __ ] years continues to
happen on sunday that's my pick paul and
i'm sticking with it there's our head to
head all right i like it we should do
that every week there's got to be a
head-to-head
one o'clock games okay that'll be
interesting wait a minute so i got miami
i got the chiefs i got the bills and i
got arizona
that's what i got and i got
i got the steelers
i got the browns and the houston oilers
i got the chargers
and i got
who's the other one
i got you
i got i got pittsburgh i got cleveland
and the chargers paul how can you forget
pittsburgh you've been riding with them
and the chargers those three oh so i go
one more i get one more yeah you had sec
you had you had second pick yeah i go
one more okay
oh all right paul is going high-powered
qb this week
paul varzey is believing in offense
the las vegas raiders are in disarray
wow i can't see it you never take a
[ __ ] chance but listen you just never
take a [ __ ] they love a headphone
apparently they love this hey man i gave
you your pick bill
okay i know but i we know the raiders
are in disarray no but i think what i'm
saying is i think that this new coach
that they all love could make them rally
that's what i'm saying oh you know what
paul i should have shut my mouth you're
100 right i apologize to you and uh all
of sicily
uh but the broncos had a loss in their
home i'm sticking with my theory give me
the denver broncos
oh [ __ ] dad i don't buy that at all
you're taking it because of disarray you
gave me a misdirection i'm not buying it
paul i'm not buying it that you almost
took the raiders
i'm not buying it paul i know you're too
long no don't do that to me
i like the homecoming theory though too
even though it's never really worked for
you
[Laughter]
you've been telling me that homecoming
theory
for [ __ ] ever
a team coming home
after a road loss
is a lock
the amount of times i've heard versi say
that and then three quarters later his
head is in his hands at a sports book
and the waitress is asking me if he's
gonna be sick and i just said no his
he's just dealing with his homecoming
theory
my my theory has always been division
rivalry games
if you don't know always take the
underdog because they play each other
twice a year these teams know each other
and it always seems to be closer that
was the only game that worked for me
last week the lions play in the rams
getting seven points bulbs the only
thing that saved me from doing the
unforgivable
all right that is our picks everybody
special let the monday night special
put some money in my pocket all right
who's playing
yeah we gotta pick three things that we
all agree on are gonna happen with this
parlay bills are gonna win josh allen's
gonna score a touchdown everybody's
gonna be covered he's gonna run it in
like a stud
all right so you got bill's winning on
the money line josh allen a rushing
touchdown and somebody's going to crack
two ribs trying to break a table to
impress some chick he doesn't know how
to talk about he's trying to bank in the
parking lot uh you bet that yet
about this uh stefan diggs reception for
a touchdown
well i already said uh josh allen
no you said josh rushing right
yes
josh allen myers
all right so we got buffalo bills
winning the game on the money line josh
allen rushing touchdown and then stefan
diggs reception for a touchdown i mean
paul that couldn't be any more
mainstream there's nothing
out of the ordinary in that
that's why i don't like it the only
thing that could [ __ ] us is josh allen
not rushing it in but he might because
he's got legs
listen paul
i'm telling you right now he's gonna run
it in it happens what happens is
everybody's covered and then that guy
runs it in just like that
is that how it happens that's exactly
how it happens what's gonna
what's gonna happen
i'm gonna break this down for you paul
everybody's gonna be covered and then
he's just going to he's going to tuck
the ball paul he's not going to be doing
this like you do when you play two
completes the first
trying to fake somebody out on the
street he's going to tuck that ball in
and i'm going to say he's actually going
to run it right up the gut
you went into that like you were
explaining how to rebuild an engine i
listen this is what's going to happen
everyone's because you know what it was
i was i was multitasking i was closing
windows so
i'm happy i just stayed on topic all
right people that are that those are our
picks
you have to be 21 years of age or older
to wager in arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis michigan minnesota new
jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia or wyoming only
uh new customer offer paid in free bets
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for arizona uh
800-522-4700 for colorado dc nevada
wyoming and virginia
800-270-7117 for confidential help
michigan 1-800 gambler indianapolis new
jersey pennsylvania west virginia 1-800
bets off for iowa call or text the
tennessee red line
800-889-9789 for tennessee or call
888-777-96964 minnesota
uh sports betting is a void in georgia
hawaii ohio and utah and other states uh
were prohibited uh promotional offers
not available in nevada
all right guys that is our week six nfl
picks and preview don't forget if you
haven't signed up
for bet mgm yet use bonus code burp
b-u-r-r and you'll get two 200
after placing your first bet of 10
bucks
uh we'll be back next week enjoy
all right that's it i gotta go all right
have have a wonderful time out there be
nice to people be kind and don't call
your boss a [ __ ]
because that's what's really gonna get
you fired okay fine
okay
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
october 14th
2013 how's it going how are you is
everything okay in your neck of the
woods
um i know what you're thinking right off
the bat jesus bill this podcast is even
later than it usually is well i will i
would counter
okay i would counter that verbal assault
by saying well didn't you have the
[ __ ] day off today
well did you well great because i did
too
i don't know why
oh it's columbus day
right
columbus day
it's columbus day
he came over here there was already
people he cut off their [ __ ] hands
because they couldn't find gold
and we celebrate him because he was kind
of white
even though i think he was from spain
and if he came to boston and tried to
get a job he'd be really [ __ ]
with most of the people he'd interview
with um what's good
um so yeah today it's columbus day
chris
christopher columbus
sorry i went to the bruins today had a
couple of beers all right so deal with
me christopher
[ __ ] cake chrissy get on the [ __ ]
boat and do the job we paid you for
christopher
columbus all right
discovered america for all you all you
people who have never picked up a uh
history book he said in 1492 he sailed
the ocean blue
he thought he was going to the west
indies this is like there once was a man
from nantucket
there once was a man from spain
uh who had in his balls of pain he
couldn't get laid
he tried every day so he said [ __ ] it
i'm gonna sail so i have something to
talk about
i don't know guys this is funny to me
and i'm buzzing pretty [ __ ] good and
i really don't give a [ __ ] i do give a
[ __ ] i care i care about you and how did
you enjoy columbus day what did you do
did you put on like a [ __ ]
george washington wig and stand on the
neck of the tannis person that you know
in celebration of all the great things
he did
um i've always had difficulty once i got
past a certain age with the fact that
that guy they said he discovered
he discovered like he discovered it for
europe
he didn't discover there was already
people here you know what i mean
just sitting here living off the land
you know a little mud flap over their
junk
using up every bit of the animal they
did nothing wrong that's the over
correction of native americans where
they've now become like these god-like
people
where none of them were bad you know
none of them would have [ __ ] you out
of your 401k money
had they understood what a 401k was
and could tie a tie you know what i mean
i mean people are people let's let's
let's let's get down to brass tacks here
people all right
just because you're sitting there
flossing with the [ __ ] bison tendon
doesn't mean
that you know if you had a car
you wouldn't get a little grabby on the
first date
all right
okay and if you can't do the math on
that then i can't help you
um
yeah it's christopher columbus day
uh marigold vispucci remember all that
that [ __ ] awful history stuff you're
sitting there with half a [ __ ]
erection looking at some chick next to
you and there's some guy in a goddamn
tweed coat
talking about uh
vinnie del negro what was the other
thing
what was what was the other guy the
other world explorer it was a marigold
vespucci
it was christopher columbus and then
there was a guy who had like a vinnie
del negro name but it wasn't vinnie del
negro but now that's in my head so i'll
never be able to think what the [ __ ] was
it
was it marcus the laffy yet
was that him he wasn't the traitor
in the uh revolutionary war that was
benedict arnold
marcus de lafayette did he start
marquette university
he did something he wasn't with lewis
and clark
i don't [ __ ] know you know what's
funny is just all the [ __ ] that was done
to create this country and they kind of
boil it down to like 14 people
these guys sailed up a river this guy
found it this guy said i can't tell a
lie
and uh the other guy said hey why don't
you lay off the black people for a
minute you know and that's pretty much
the first 200 years
of history
in this country as far as i can tell you
know and for all you europeans listening
and all you australians that doesn't
mean your country's better
all right
so [ __ ] you and your fish and chips and
your vegemite sandwiches because nobody
gives a [ __ ] all right
you're just as filthy as we are which
brings me to a wonderful [ __ ]
conversation that i had
with uh paul verzi
paul verzi right so
neither one of us has watched baseball
in a while i stopped in 2010 when uh
poppy tested for some substance and they
never said what it was
and at that point pretty much everybody
from the o4 series
like five guys on both teams had tested
positive or whatever so it was kind of
fair i guess i wrote it up guys beat
your write it up guys but it was just
getting annoyed and i'm not saying poppy
was doing any [ __ ] but that was just one
of those things was like listen i've
watched enough [ __ ] train wrecks i
don't want to watch this one
either get it out of the game or do what
you know you're going to do in the long
haul which is you're going to make the
[ __ ] legal
all right
i love how a football player who is
running around tackling people at the
nfl level which is basically
like getting into a [ __ ] car accident
you know not a major one but a pretty
significant one you gotta exchange
you know insurance cards
like every other [ __ ] play he can't
do roids but a [ __ ] some singer
can't get on stage and be like
they can't [ __ ] do that then it's
okay for them to give roids
to get some roids right in their old
[ __ ] voice box
look up at the ceiling there [ __ ] uh
vladimir
whatever the [ __ ] your name is fatty
with the beard what is that guy's name
he was the guy he was part of the three
tenors
you know
he looked like franco harris if he was
white
what the [ __ ] is that guy's name
and he was bald jesus christ it's like
anybody knows
like everybody knows one opera singer
and this is the guy
right
whatever that [ __ ] guy
i don't even know how i got onto that
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] was i talking i'm talking about
versi
all right
so me and varsi have not watched oh so
much steroids before i was talking about
verses steroids yeah
that [ __ ] synergenic [ __ ] that you
watch late at night where they show some
old guy with his gut hanging out
right
he's got a tattoo of rosie the riveter
right above where his [ __ ] spleen
used to be
and he's just done
he's got creases in his torso that it
doesn't even make sense it's not even
like fat creases it means like organs
have been removed and there's a space
there now that can only be filled up
with the flesh on the outside of your
torso one of those kinds of creases
okay
and then by the end of the commercial
that guy's standing there looking like
[ __ ] gronkowski
and he's hanging out with some [ __ ]
35 year old chick who wasn't raised
right
clearly her dad took off
so now she has the big strong father
figure that she always wanted
and i'm sitting there going well jesus
christ i thought p90x was impressive
that was getting people in their 20s 30s
and 40s in shape
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] and i went up
i went on the internet
the old interweb as they call it on my
favorite [ __ ] show on tv fast and
loud
uh i went on the interweb
and uh
i looked it up to see what the [ __ ] was
and it's uh it's
it's hgh
that's what they're doing and they're
sitting there going like with our system
as far as my research goes before i get
in trouble here as far as my research
according to my research which was
basically i looked up synergenics
scam question mark and the first thing
came up was what they were giving these
people human growth hormone well
obviously
human growth homework and then you give
them a [ __ ] handful of viagra they go
out and they hit the clubs
right
go over to the [ __ ] jukebox they put
on a little [ __ ] glenn miller
glenn miller little moonlight serenade
the next thing you know some [ __ ]
broad from this generation with their
glow sticks and too many tattoos in her
giant [ __ ] earlobes that you could
stick a pool cue through
right next thing you know she's dropped
to her [ __ ]
dubstep knees
and she's blowing a veteran of the
korean war that's how it goes down
okay and that right there people is the
upside of steroids
you know
look at all these [ __ ] ladies when
you're watching the real housewives
those aren't real housewives
those are a a higher breed of housewife
okay
i'm just loving all the women right now
just oh my god how could you say that
i'll tell you why
because this is the deal they still had
they had children and they're still
despite the limits of modern day science
is this still trying to look like a hot
piece of ass now they're not doing it
but i'm telling you right now just like
that guy that you love that goes into
the corner right that guy that little
[ __ ] return punch the [ __ ] wedge
breaker the guy who's all [ __ ] hard
that's the female version of the wedge
baker breaker right there it's those
broads
on the [ __ ]
real housewives
looking [ __ ] into your 50s
god bless you making people do double
takes like is that 20 oh wait a minute
no no she's 55. gross but there is that
moment
you know what i mean
you got to give it up to them
i don't even know what i'm talking about
i'm a couple of loggers in
i went to the bruins game today i had no
[ __ ] intentions of going wait stay on
stay on target
i'll get to the bruins game in a [ __ ]
second
um so versi last night you know i'm the
biggest
you couldn't be more of a bandwagon red
sox fan this year unless you started
after game three
of the tampa bay series the first two
games red sox games i watched this year
was game one in game two of the tampa
bay uh playoffs and then i missed the
rest of the series i travel you know
what i mean i i i'm into lego
collectibles i have a schedule
um
is there such a thing
anyways
and i've watched the uh the first two
games of this tiger city city this tiger
series and it is an instant [ __ ]
classic if you guys are like me and you
went away from the game for a couple of
years
uh this is a great one
great one to come back to the first one
was an absolute
gem
one nothing game it was one of those
deals where the tigers won one nothing
and i felt like we lost like eight
nothing i mean they were just [ __ ]
mowing us down
all right
huge loss
huge loss so now they they got the
[ __ ] upper hand in the city so now on
the series why do i keep saying city i
don't know
probably because you were drinking but
hard
um
i'm like there they automatically have
the upper hand in the in the series
right now we have to win game two look
what the [ __ ] they did
so then they got this other psycho i
don't know anybody's names and i got
other than cabrera because he won the
triple crown and i got to tell you
something right now
the athletic gifts that that man was
given that he can be in the [ __ ]
horrific shape that he's in and still
win the triple crown he is in joe
derosa's shape
okay when i look at joe derosa
when i bite into a york peppermint patty
when i look at joe derosa i look at a
man
who has never done a push-up in his life
other than
after he's been drunk and he fell down
and did a face plant and even then it's
a girl push-up right with his [ __ ]
corduroid knees in the grass
and if he's on a [ __ ] hill that
favors him if he's facing up the hill he
can actually get his horrific
[ __ ] uh uh example of a torso up off
of that grass
why am i trashing joe he's not here to
defend himself ah jesus joe did somebody
[ __ ] send this to you because they're
miserable
um
yeah that cabrera guy jesus what a
[ __ ] awful
horrible
he looks like he should be selling like
concessions
and he's eating them too he's just got a
puffy face
he's got a flabby neck
and it's like he's not fat he's not in
shape he's just sort of [ __ ] you know he
runs around
but when he's done he's eating like a
[ __ ] bowl of mint chocolate chip
you know what it reminds me of like
warren sapp whenever i used to watch
warren sapp play i'm just used to
remember like what would happen if this
guy actually [ __ ] worked out
what if he actually worked out
warren sapp was in worse shape than most
of the people
in the stands that were watching him
just you know to look at him
i used to always think i used to i
thought i was like towards the end of
his career one of these years he's gonna
say [ __ ] it and he's gonna come in with
a flat stomach
and
he's going to reach like reggie white
level
defensive end and he never did it
he never did it so anyway so versi
i text him i'm in boston right
and i'm watching the [ __ ] red sox
game
and he puts him on and you you have to
understand red sox yankee hatred
is paul has even watched the game in i
don't know a couple of years right the
second
i don't think he was watching the game
for more than three seconds and he just
starts sending me
tweet after [ __ ] tweet about how
awful the [ __ ] red sox beards are
he just he was beside himself he thought
it was a disgrace to the game the
reality is he just he hates the [ __ ]
reds i mean i don't like their beards
either but like
let's see here let me read some of this
[ __ ]
um
where the [ __ ] is it
ah [ __ ] this oh load earlier messages
dude we were texting so much during the
game i had to go all the way
you don't have the success to take the
slot what the [ __ ] is this where the
hell is it
let me get to the top up here
i'm sorry guys i'm the worst
now this is me talking about paul and
the mob you get whacked for running your
mouth
with a [ __ ] ass is it even gonna be
worth it at this point
jesus christ built load earlier messages
here we go
all right where the [ __ ] am i
okay this is what mercy writes he says i
just turned it on because i said poppy
grand slam tie game
oh by the way
oh like not a bunch of tiger fans but
about a half dozen of them were just
trashing me
um
just saying the series over
better better luck next year red sucks
when they were up five nothing in game
two about you know seven innings in and
all i just kept thinking in my head is
like dude have you ever watched a
baseball game before
it's like they're running out of time
as long as there's no outs it goes on
forever it's like that george carlin bit
there's plenty of [ __ ] time
so anyways long story short they [ __ ]
load them up and poppy hits a grand slam
to tie the game so i write poppy grand
slam tie game
first he writes i just turned it on
exclamation point
and i was thinking like wow he's going
to be like all right awesome game
immediately his first sentence dude the
sox beards are so [ __ ]
stupid they the whole anti-yankee facial
hair
is so douchey they look ridiculous grow
up babies lol
and then we just start going back and
forth
he said you guys look like lumberjack
morons you're baseball players the worst
and i just keep going like oh you know
where did derek jeter watch the game
tonight and of course he's like uh on
[ __ ] miss universe's [ __ ] i'm like
isn't he like 38 at this point it's
starting to get creepy isn't it
he really is like some zillionaire guy
still going to [ __ ] hooters that's
just jealousy on my part anyway so we
just start [ __ ]
giving each other [ __ ] the [ __ ] was my
point to this
dude half your team looks like they're
in a [ __ ] halloween halloween costume
it's embarrassing
and then i wrote back not as
embarrassing as missing the playoffs
uh what would you do if a comedy club
had a no facial hair policy
he writes back to shave but we don't
look like [ __ ]
i'd be working still working stand up i
don't know what the [ __ ] this i can't
get into this because i started saying
what comedians would actually be
would play for the yankees versus the
one for the red sox just to give you a
hint the red sox had sam kinnison and
all the badass ones
and uh the yankees had all the [ __ ]
clean cut
i don't know you know the deal i don't
know i know the podcast just went off
the [ __ ] rails give me a break okay i
went with a head of steam
okay what are you gonna do but i gotta
tell you something that whole yankee
[ __ ] thing about no facial hair i'm
old enough to remember in the 70s when
they all look like they were gonna go
shoot a [ __ ] porno and then out of
nowhere they started taking on this
[ __ ] holier than now like notre dame
horseshit
you know
we we're clean shaven we're we and
verzi's going yeah they look like
gentlemen it's like paul they're a bunch
of roided up [ __ ] just like everybody
else just because they look like they're
gonna deliver a [ __ ] newspaper to you
all of a sudden that makes them better
give me a [ __ ] break i like that the
red sox look like the moon dogs you know
for you old [ __ ] wrestling fans
i don't give a [ __ ] just as long as as
long as they win it's gonna be a great
series i think it's going seven
and uh i'm actually a big fan of the
tigers and that type of stuff i had
family that grew up in michigan so uh
i like the tigers i got no i got no beef
with those guys but what the [ __ ] was i
gonna bring up here
um
was it time to read a [ __ ] yeah it is
it's time to do a little uh
ah jesus yeah where the [ __ ] is it okay
here we go here we go uh dollar shave
club everybody
you know there's so many things in this
world that irritate me
uh paul verzi's uh misguided anger about
the red sox beards when he should just
really say i'm really sad that my team
isn't in the playoffs and you guys have
a really good shot at winning the world
series but instead
he he turns into like joan rivers like
he's on the red carpet
you know
dustin pedroia what are you wearing
um what so many things can irritate you
wide at why add razors to the list
it's time to stop milking your razor
blade come on we've all done it you know
the deal you know with the brand name
razors they're like a zillion dollars
you pay outrageous prices so you sit
there and you try to squeeze the life
out of these razors until they start
feeling like a rusty soda can dragging
across your face
all right well guess what it's time to
move on dollar shave club delivers
amazing quality blades right to your
goddamn door for just a few bucks a
month my listeners have been taking
advantage of this ad like no other ad
and i have not gotten one complaint
but now that i've said that i will get
my first complaint but i will guarantee
you there will be no more
this this out of all of them has been an
absolute home run all right you never
have to think about getting razor blades
again they send a pack every month so
you can change change your blades once a
week i love these guys you're gonna love
them too uh they've also has a new
product called the one wipe jolly
uh it's a butt wipe for men and it's
classy check out the video for that and
sign up for your raises today go to the
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
that's
dollarshaveclub.comforwardslashburr or
go to billboard.com and click the dollar
shave club banner today
and as always hulu plus everybody this
is a whole new way to watch television
all right where you you you my friend
are the head of the network you decide
when and where and what all right well
here's the deal you probably tried
hulu.com well now it's time to try hulu
plus you can watch your favorite shows
anytime anywhere hulu plus lets you
watch thousands of hit tv shows and a
selection of acclaimed movies on your
television or on the go with your
smartphone or tablet and it all streams
in hd for the best viewing experience
you can't beat this with hulu plush you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like saturday night live community
family guy south park breaking bad
whatever the hell you want to watch you
can also check out exclusive content
including hulu originals they have
original series like the awesomes
starring snl seth myers
and moon boy starring chris o'dowd from
bridesmaid
uh hulu plus also offers a great
selection of acclaimed films for only
7.99 a month you can stream as many tv
shows and movies as you want whenever
you want you're out of your mind if you
don't do this right now you can try hulu
plus for free for two weeks when you go
to huluplus.com bill that's a special
offer offer for my listeners make sure
you use hulupus.com bill so you get the
extended free trial and they know that
we sent you go to huluplus.com bill
now or click the hulu plus banner on the
podcast page at billboard.com
um all right
back to the podcast here
oh you know what's [ __ ] hilarious to
me i i got to do a paul versi here and
say dude i called it because i did call
it
all right
where the hell's mike [ __ ] god damn
yes i'm the worst i am the absolute
worst there it is
weeks ago when i first started making
fun of seattle the seattle seahawks
going for the loudest record just to
give you a recap i basically said well
hey when you haven't won a championship
you have to hang your hat on something
and if you get this record are you going
to start singing we are the loudest my
friends and we'll keep on losing
screaming until we lose that [ __ ]
and i said
you can go back it's documented on my
podcast i said
that seattle seahawks fans were not that
loud that it was the building i'm not
saying that they're not good fans but
they're not as [ __ ] loud as
everyone's making them out to be you go
to the game and it's so [ __ ] loud
you're looking around and you're looking
at people while they're cheering and
you're like that face does not add up to
this loud are they piping noise in and
it turns out their owner had built a
stadium
specifically designed to contain the
noise so it's like a crowd
on [ __ ] hgh they're a bunch of
cheaters they're the jason g armbies of
crowds and from day [ __ ] one when i
broke their balls about it i said i went
to a kansas city chiefs game
and those [ __ ] were louder than the
ones in seattle and they this weekend
broke the record for the loudest crowd
which is the dumbest [ __ ] record ever
um
the loudest crowd and they did it in a
stadium that was built when we still
thought the vietnam war was winnable all
right
so it's not even like they just beat
seattle they destroyed them
okay so now i have a new song
for the seattle seahawks fans out of
respect for them
and their one week of holding the title
they held the title for one week kind of
like when the heavyweight champion gets
arrested or refuses to go to war and
they just strip him of his title and
they give it to some [ __ ] palooka
and he has it for one week until he gets
knocked out that's what happened to them
so here's their new song all right
we
were the loudest for one week
and then a bunch of red cuts
in kansas city boo boo boo screamed a
little louder
hey you know what's funny i don't have a
[ __ ] talk for you know what's [ __ ]
hilarious is kansas city at least has
won a super bowl everybody
when did they do it
come on they were still in the afl
boo boo boo boo boo boo boo super bowl 4
lenny dawson
63 toss power trap whatever the [ __ ] it
was
hank sram with that rolled up thing in
the [ __ ] hairpiece walking up and
down chewing his gum
that was when the vikings the original
buffalo bills lost their first
of soon-to-be four super bowls
um inexplicably
they had fran tarkinton they had the
purple people eaters they had paul
krauss they had [ __ ] chuck foreman
they had freddy cox kicking the goddamn
ball and nothing happened
uh
hey you know i mentioned earlier that um
so seattle i'm just breaking your
[ __ ] balls all right so you know
don't cry in the rain and blow your
[ __ ] brains out
like that guy did
okay
and then his stripper wife read his
[ __ ] suicide note to every anyone who
would want to listen which was arguably
uh
the greatest example of stealing someone
else's thunder i've ever seen
you know
how do you blow your own head off and
not get top billing i mean it's just
[ __ ] insane
i'll tell you how somebody comes in and
reads your suicide note and is emoting
about how devastated they are you know
it's like it wasn't your day lady
all right it was what's left of that guy
up there in the [ __ ] attic
uh all right that seemed really
insensitive but i am a fan of all of the
people mentioned
listen
sometimes i hurt feelings on this
podcast but what i'm going for is i'm
trying
to streamline what it is that i say and
sometimes i don't have time for names
and sometimes i don't have time for
feelings
okay
but that doesn't mean
that i'm not i'm not a fan
of whether whatever it is you do
okay and if you can't do the math on
that then
i really can't help you um
i mentioned earlier that i am a big fan
of uh fast and loud
that's like my favorite [ __ ] tv show
now that breaking bad is over i
absolutely [ __ ] love that show i love
cars
i love watching people that know how to
fix them up but the funniest [ __ ]
thing ever is watching the dude richard
richard rawlings
watching him bust these people down on
cars is the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean dude he
beats the [ __ ] out of him i i i don't
think i
i don't remember laughing
as much as i laugh when i watch that
show he [ __ ] destroys him
he'll go out there right
it's always the same [ __ ] somebody's got
a thunderbird they got a corvette
they got some mopar thing or whatever
and he comes walking out he's always
complimentary of the car
when he wants it
so he gets people excited
like they're going to make a sale they
just don't realize how low much lower
it's going to be so he always comes in
and he goes wow man look at this huh
it's a 60 68 yeah wow boss sits right
body straight everything's cool but blah
blah blah blah
and then he always looks at him he just
goes uh so
uh
what were you thinking
and then the owner's always like
i mean i don't know i was thinking uh
i was thinking like 30
and then richard i don't give a [ __ ]
what they say he always just goes like
oh man man i can't do 30.
i i can't i can't i mean i drove all the
way out here i got i got to tow it back
i
i can't i can't do 30. right so then the
person who owns the car always says the
same [ __ ] well well what would uh you
know
come my way a little bit well what were
you thinking and he's he always hits his
hands in his pocket and he acts like
he's thinking about it but you know he
isn't he knew what the [ __ ] he was
offering the second he walked into the
barn and he'll say like i was thinking
like
like 12.
[Laughter]
dude they go from 30
he takes them down to 12. so these guys
like ah i mean i can't do 12.
come on man i can't do that i can't do
that
and then they then they always come down
quick and they go how about like 24 can
you do 24 and then he comes back like
man i could do like 13 and he's just
inching up and then dropping like a
[ __ ] elevator that got its cables cut
my favorite one i ever saw
was he went in and bought like this 62
corvette off these these people right
and he was sitting in this [ __ ] damp
warehouse spooky looking [ __ ] saw
kind of place
and they buy the [ __ ] thing the guy
wanted 30 grand for it and he busted him
down to 18-5
so he brings the [ __ ] thing back i
mean it's a corvette so you can't see
any rust because it's a fiberglass body
but when they look underneath it it's
just rusted out
to the point of like dude well i don't
why did we pick this car up
but as luck would have it
the guy who sold him the car there was
it was actually his grandfather's car
and there was people part of his family
tree that were like you shouldn't have
sold that car that car was supposed to
be for us
so they go down to the gas monkey garage
to buy this [ __ ] car back
all right
so richard's psyched he hasn't to do
hasn't had to do anything for it right
he paid 18-5 for it
you know busted the guy down from 30. so
the guy's own family members
his nephew and his brother come in to
buy the car back
they tell him the whole [ __ ] story
and then richard's like yeah cool man
you can buy it back and they were like
so
what were you thinking and he goes
you know i was thinking like 30.
[Laughter]
after busting the guy from 30 down to
18-5 he goes right back to that guy's
price so the the cousin and the [ __ ]
uncle they're like hey stupid you bought
the car from my brother we know what you
paid for it's the only time i've ever
seen him get embarrassed he's like oh
i'm sorry man that's just what we do
here he's like how about 22 and he ended
up selling it for [ __ ]
you know 20 grand i don't know i i
probably just butchered all that but
fast and loud
you got to check it out um
i like it because they build cars that i
feel like i could afford they don't have
like that mecums [ __ ] where everything's
six figures i mean they they build like
a badass car for like 25 30 grand
after they paid like you know 10 grand
for it and redid everything i really
like that show so uh
shout out to anybody who list who's on
that show that listens to this podcast i
[ __ ] love it um anyways what are we
up to here what am i talking about
what am i looking at here i am
31 minutes in
was there anything else i wanted to talk
about how about the patriots huh i
watched that game on the flight
that was unbelievable the last two
touchdowns in that game were
you couldn't find a better example
of uh
worst defense
i've ever seen in my [ __ ] life the
patriots had double coverage
got the safety coming over the top
our quarterback's in position to swat
down the ball and he swings at it like a
[ __ ] change up and it goes right by
him and the guy scores for a [ __ ]
touchdown
brutal
and then when he brady threw an
interception we went down the field and
the [ __ ] saints turn around do the
exact same thing in single coverage it
was like neither team wanted to win the
game but i want to chastise
all those [ __ ] patriots fans that
left
that [ __ ] left like half the stadium
looked like it left
and i know a lot of people like girl
boss patriots fans suck it's like [ __ ]
you your fans suck too half of your fans
suck that's what you have to understand
about any any arena you go to the only
reason why it is this it is the size
that it is is it's because someday
you're gonna make a run at the title
and they're going to need all those
extra seats
all right but the reality is
is when the team starts [ __ ] in the bed
half the people leave so those stadiums
only need like patriot state it really
only needs to hold 30 000 people you
know if you had to sign an agreement
that i don't give a [ __ ] if they're
fourteen and two or two and fourteen i'm
coming to the games you know i don't
think it needs to be thirty thousand so
uh
i love that all those [ __ ] left and
they have to go to work tomorrow and lie
and say that they were there
uh the red sox were great
most of people stayed
a couple two or three people i saw leave
saw a couple empty seats but everybody
stayed it was just a great [ __ ]
weekend and i went to the bruins game
today i was actually walking over to the
to uh the garden and i was just gonna
buy a hat
and uh all of a sudden here guys uh who
needs tickets who needs tickets
i knew they were playing the red wigs
but i thought it was in detroit and i
said [ __ ] it
i'll go to the goddamn game so i go into
the game i'm like not gonna drink drink
a little water come back do the [ __ ]
podcast and what happens in between the
[ __ ] first and second period or
second and third period i run into an
old drinking buddy of mine from back in
the day
the high school days
pick up right where we left off i'll
have one
you know [ __ ] three beers later here
we are so my apologies for being uh late
and congratulations to the red wings
uh it wasn't the greatest the [ __ ]
games
matinee games usually suck
you know there's usually an extra
sort of like uh
mascot presence because there's so many
kids there
they usually don't fight you know which
makes sense right
i want to ask you guys when's the last
time you got into a fist fight at like
two o'clock in the afternoon doesn't
happen
fist fights happen at night
i don't know why they just do it feels
right
um
all right is that it is that all i have
to talk about before i get into the
letters
um
chief seattle fast and loud red sox
patriots prunes oh the half marathon
i just make little notes here [ __ ] to
talk about i was [ __ ] walking through
uh
the boston commons walking through the
pack
and they were having this half marathon
and all it was was [ __ ] ladies
and uh
[ __ ] women look phenomenal they were
crushing it right running down the
street zero [ __ ] body fat but still
had booties on them i was loving every
[ __ ] second of it right
objectifying them as they tried to have
a nice
day of exercise
so as i get closer to the finish line
there's some woman on the mic and it's i
don't know like she was just being so
overly positive it was annoying the [ __ ]
out of me
she was announcing every woman that
crossed the finish line
i get announcing like the [ __ ] top 10
15 20.
but the it took me like 20 minutes to
walk through the park from one side to
the other side up by the state house and
all i hear the whole time and uh you
know
marissa
clifford from attleboro
he's just yelling everybody's name
abigail
twitzelnitzel from marblehead today is
your day
that's what she said about one of them
today is your day and i want to be like
she [ __ ] came in like 70th
it's not her day
it's not nearly a day she needs to
[ __ ] go home
and look at some game film
it's not her [ __ ] day it's not a day
by a long shot she's a coach she's fired
in the first third of that race
bringing in an interim runner
today's your [ __ ] day it's just
[ __ ] ridiculous you know i get it
guys run the world we're a bunch of
dicks we don't give you your [ __ ] do
so
but i got to tell you there is a way of
over correcting to the point where all
you're doing is making everybody there
soft but i got to tell you those women
running the races i'm telling you they
probably didn't like that either
they probably didn't like it either you
know what i mean
they're all [ __ ] athletes
are you an athlete if you're a runner
okay you just put up with a lot of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'll tell you what i like about my girl
man she's got endurance i came home and
bitched about my job for four hours last
night she never complained
uh
i know that was just one of those
moments where i was just sitting there
listening to this [ __ ] woman
screaming out all these women's names
you know betty [ __ ] whoever
congratulations
i don't understand you would think that
all of them won some regional [ __ ]
running thing and now they were showing
up hyping the race they were gonna run
rather than that person she just
mentioned came in 47th
oh bill you know what the holidays are
coming up why don't you put a [ __ ]
red nose on and [ __ ] take the cut
down a little bit all right you might be
right
okay so anyways kansas city is
officially the loudest crowd
and at the end of the day nobody i think
it's funny because i was trash in
seattle but nobody gives a [ __ ]
okay
kansas city wants what seattle wants
wants what the patriots wants wants what
everybody [ __ ] wants
you want the super bowl title that's
what you will be the loudest
that's stupid
the seattle fans are the [ __ ] worst
the way you you guys so quickly came
back to that odor that [ __ ] you over
so bad on the tall boy beards that were
just as big as the small ones
what a shame and he buys you back
because he [ __ ] calls you 12th man
and waves a [ __ ] flag you know
something seattle i thought you were
better than that
and it hurts me to say that i guess i
was wrong
uh
i got the amount of people that are
actually going to take that seriously
[Laughter]
okay
follow up to bully
all right i guess this is one you can
tell i've come
i've been going down coming down with a
little bit of a cold here that's what
happens when you drink like 12 nights in
a row
you know it's not really the alcohol
it's the uh being out until four in the
morning without a hat on
uh follow up to bully
billy redface this is a follow-up to the
email i sent about getting picked on oh
this is the big dude right the big dude
at school who could do something
he's at the dojo and all that type of
[ __ ] but didn't want to do something
because he didn't want to dis disappoint
his senseis if i'm using the right
karate lingo
if i'm not i mean i i my apologies
anyways he said it went a lot better
than i expected
oh to give you a recap this guy was like
a big guy and there was some [ __ ]
shorter fat kid that was always coming
up slapping him in the head at school
and this guy seems like he's studying at
least two if not three different martial
arts disciplines and if he wanted to
okay
could you know
you know that [ __ ] that they do i don't
even know what they do next you know
that you feel the heat of their foot
next to your ear
and then you you know you wake up near a
computer watching the youtube video
whatever the [ __ ] just happened to you
he could basically do that but he didn't
because he didn't want to disappoint
disappoint
his martial arts teachers all right
jesus bill all right here we go he said
it went a lot better than i expected i
told one of my martial arts teachers and
he basically gave me a green light to
whoop this kid
but not too bad no broken bones except
maybe the nose
oh i love this guy this guy's old school
he said i walked into the locker room
and he greeted me with hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
i replied with i hear your birthday's
coming up what's your cup size
he got pretty mad and said what'd you
[ __ ] say
i said your cup size you fat [ __ ] what
is it i love it
did you see the [ __ ] [ __ ] in him
coming out
he said he walked at me and swung a
haymaker
i took it on the chin jesus christ you
didn't slip he said i beat the [ __ ] out
of this kid
well it's good because he took a swing
first very nice
goes i need him in the belly twice once
to the head i kicked him in the thigh oh
that's the one he's gonna feel tomorrow
oh that one's gonna that one's gonna
bruise and he goes and he went down
i finished with a few punches to the
head i got suspended for two days after
they heard he was picking on me i think
it's safe to say he won't be picking on
anyone else anymore have a great day and
please say
uh [ __ ] kyle that's an inside joke with
one of my friends all right dude good
for you
good for you you know something good for
your teacher you know what i mean
can't always be holding people up at
third base every once in a while you
gotta wave them around
here comes the throw at the plate right
good for you
i was gonna say i wish i could watch the
video of it but you'd get in trouble for
it so
by the way i'm drinking water that
annoying sound is ice water i'm not
still drinking on this thing all right
here's a new topic
that is hasn't come up which i wish it
would come up more often
lesbian love
uh dear dr burr i have a bit of a girl
dilemma here
i'm a 26 year old dude living in
connecticut
uh [ __ ] hartford
okay so you're living anywhere but
hartford or you're in hartford you hate
it
he said i met a girl oh wait a minute if
this is coming from a guy all i see is
threesome on the horizon
all right
please let this go the way i want it to
go
said i met a girl through a friend of a
friend and we became great friends she
lives out of state but we still keep in
touch and communicate with each other
whenever we can
all right you paint with a broad brush
here that could be
you text every once in a while or you're
having [ __ ] you're sexting
or [ __ ] you know pressing your dick
up against your computer while skyping i
mean there's a lot of there's a you know
it's a lot of room for interpretation
there sir but i'll continue he says
she's independent headstrong not
materialistic likes the same [ __ ] i do
and we are always in sync whenever we
get together person to person basically
perfect for me and not to sound corny at
some point i fell in love with her do
don't ever apologize for falling in love
with the woman that's just some guy [ __ ]
where you can't pretend like you want to
be happy too good for you
he said but she's a lesbian and then he
writes oh
geez
oh well dude did you know that going
into it
the voice cracking did you know that
going into it you didn't protect your
[ __ ] hat
um
are you doing the chick thing where you
think you can change her
uh
all right he says it's a bit of an
emotional struggle i would think so
he said i've already shared my feelings
and obviously they went nowhere
so now you know what i'm thinking now
when you said she likes the same [ __ ]
you like yeah
i can see where you guys would be on the
same page
checking out the ladies so anyways he
goes so now i gotta bottle that [ __ ] up
inside it's been like that for almost a
year part of me still wants to be
friends with her but the other parts of
me tells me to forget about her and cut
all communications off yeah i mean or
you just keep looking at her
going oh maybe she'll blow me today
ain't happening uh he said i'd feel like
a douche [ __ ] you guys are really
creating odd
like uh vulgarities here a douche [ __ ]
okay that's a new one if i cut all ties
and yet i know it's gonna suck for me
emotional as long as i'm friends with
her because i'll never be with her or
will this feeling go away eventually my
friends keep telling me to forget about
her but i will always be losing an
awesome but i would also be losing an
awesome friend too what do you think
bill should i listen to my heart or my
[ __ ]
thanks go [ __ ] yourself truly
uh
[Music]
let's see
i would say uh
listen to your heart or you caught i
don't know which ones to do what
your heart loves her and you also want
to [ __ ] her all you have to do is you
need to do a combo
like you have to have a sit down with
both your heart and your dick and just
be like look
all right
your dick has to know the score at this
point
it ain't happening
okay
your dick probably already has its
[ __ ] helmet off it's taking his tape
off and all that [ __ ] but your heart
you know
i don't know what your [ __ ] heart so
listen dude
i'm sorry i'm buzzed here
uh
what do i think you should do uh yeah i
think you should you should just walk
away
you gotta walk away and you got to be
into
some other chick first and then maybe
you can start to be friends again
but uh
yeah it sounds like you've been a sad
puppy dog with blue balls for a year and
i'd say you've uh i think you've done
your pennants
you know why don't you go into the uh
the open lane
why don't you do that
i just opened the register can i
can i have the next customer please go
into that [ __ ] line
all right
oh man that sucks
i feel bad for you dude
what are you going to do
you know i saw the other day on the
cover espen espn magazine they had one
of those ufc chicks like totally naked
but with their [ __ ]
her goddamn hands wrapped
and i gotta tell you something man i
think those those women are hot
they are [ __ ] hot and i think it
would make you a better person if you
could date if you went out with a woman
that could beat the [ __ ] out of you
just because it would fall it wouldn't
it would force you to be smarter
the reason why women are smarter than us
is because basically speaking we can
[ __ ] stuff them in a hamper if we
want to so they have to outsmart us so
it's from day one they're using their
[ __ ] brains
well we're just sitting there going shut
up you know using force
there's nothing we're all [ __ ] knees
and elbows so what would happen is is
you would gain the wisdom of a female by
kind of being the [ __ ] in the
relationship in that
you know she could [ __ ] slap you
around
then you could learn to use tricks like
guilt
you know who knows maybe she'd go out
and get you a pair of shoes
right i'm sorry so
sorry that i put you
in a kimura
um i've been meaning to watch that ufc
show where they have the women in the
house uh it's hard to watch women
beating the [ __ ] out of each other
there's like no way that they can hit
them hit each other that it's [ __ ]
pleasant to see
punching them in their pretty faces or
even worse when they take that [ __ ]
straight right to the left hit it's just
like what are you doing
you know i might be misogynistic here
but i just look that's like for a baby
why are they punching you in one of your
[ __ ] uh
baby compartments
i really have a [ __ ] i admit it you
know whatever that's just how i look at
it i'll tell you what at least i'm
honest
at least i'm honest that's when you know
you said some ignorant [ __ ] and half the
parties walking away from you
hey hey you know i say what's on my mind
i say what's up well maybe sometimes you
shouldn't
all right here we go
i work in hell with no escape
hey billy redbeard by the pirate i'm a
police officer in a town in new jersey
where i am an 11-year veteran
all right hang in there dude you're over
the hump what do you need 20 years
i said keep it moving you got to do that
for another nine years
uh the department i work for abuses
those of us who have too much
self-respect to kiss ass
all right now i'm not trying to be a
dick sir but you've already painted
yourself as the hero here
all right but i'm gonna believe you
okay
i'm gonna believe that you actually do a
good job and the reason why they don't
like you is not cause you're [ __ ] uh
being a [ __ ]
it's because you don't kiss any ass all
right
i'm gonna go with that
he said it's gotten so bad that they
suspend and even try to fire guys who
don't bow down and kiss the ring
it's the very different definition of a
hostile work environment and i'm
terribly stressed out about the
situation now you may be asking yourself
is it so bad why don't you move on to
another police department thank you sir
for giving me the credit
for being that intelligent to have that
thought unfortunately i didn't
i was immediately thinking that you
should get together
with some other your friends and become
the serpacos out there
you know maybe deep pants your [ __ ]
uh cpo whatever the [ __ ] his name is
you know start hazing him
have a little mutiny
uh anyways he said well i've tried but
the greatest the great [ __ ] up state
of new jersey has a rule that says if if
i transfer to another police department
both of the department i work for and
the department i want to go to have to
approve and sign off on the transfer i
was this close to getting hired by
another department it was denied the
transfer by my current police chief
or as i called him satan
apparently they could do that i hate
stress but i have bad dreams about the
place and it affects my mood when i
think about it even when i'm off my
question to you is if i'm stuck in the
worst work environment imaginable how do
i shake off the [ __ ] and not worry
thanks for all the laughs and i
underestimated your ticket selling
ability in new jersey i was a little
late trying to get tickets to red bank
oh you know
that's not that big a place sir um but i
appreciate the compliment um
all right
well here's the deal
you can't ever let some other [ __ ]
affect your happiness
happiness
all right
it's all going to come down to how you
choose to react to what it is he's doing
that's the first step
all right
i mean i know this is a completely
different
scenario but i remember i used to live
above this [ __ ] angry old man
and he used to always yell at me every
[ __ ] thing i did my old apartment you
know when i drop his cell phone he keep
it up
do it again all that [ __ ] and he yelled
at me and all that [ __ ] so
i um
i just started hitting him with
positivity
you know
me and nia just started acting like he
was attractive
i just walked by hey what do you say
that good looking
she'd whistle at him like he was sexy
and it kind of brought him around in
some weird way now i don't know if you
can do that
can you do that can you [ __ ] with your
your
superior officer like that
when he comes in he needs to cut to you
and just be hey sarge have you been
losing weight
you're really filling out that uniform
quite nicely
just keep doing that uncomfortable [ __ ]
to him
and then uh i don't know if he's truly
as bad as you say you can't tell me some
of the other guys you work with don't
feel the same [ __ ] thing
i know you have the code
of silence the blue code whatever the
[ __ ] it is
you know
but if somebody's being that much of a
dick at some point i'm not saying to rat
the guy out
well maybe you know
can you organize something
or is everybody's too nervous that they
won't get another stripe on their
[ __ ] costume
is that what it is
i don't [ __ ] know sir you know what
is i can just tell you i feel for you i
don't know what to tell you talking
about cops here he's got a goddamn gun
um
i would just start sending them flowers
and chocolates
like this positive
way just annoy the [ __ ] out of him
you know i'd leave him little
love letters
on his car you don't need to sign it i
would just start [ __ ] with them
just to give yourself something
that is he's being a [ __ ] to you you
know that he's going to go out there and
read you know his secret mail admirer
love letter just something something to
[ __ ] with the guy
what else could you do
ah there's the usual [ __ ] laxatives
i i would do i don't know what i would
do i would sing like the mary tyler
moore song to him every time he was a
dick to me
who can turn the world on with his smile
well it's you sarge and you should know
it
with each little [ __ ] [ __ ] move you
show it
why are you such a dick
it's just [ __ ]
this is a great thing about humor if
it's funny it's fine
you just gotta make sure you get a laugh
and other than that
i would um
you know dude you got another nine years
you can't let somebody take a decade
from you here so i would i would do
whatever it is i had to do
you know grab some beers with some of
the other guys you probably can't trust
them there's always some kiss ass that's
gonna [ __ ] rat you out i don't want
to ruin your career here jesus dude i
don't know what to tell you
i would just i mean other than the
[ __ ] singing songs to him
yeah he comes in and he's telling you
some [ __ ] you don't want to do just look
right at him dead seriously god you have
beautiful eyes
just something like that just keep
[ __ ] with them because that's a way
where you can still carry out whatever
[ __ ] order he told you to do but you
still hold on to a piece of yourself
that's the best i have for you other
than that i would explore some sort of
organized way
okay
to [ __ ] tip this guy over in his
squad car
i hope i helped you out sir because that
uh i got miserable reading that all
right okay where the [ __ ] are we
55 minutes in have i done i think it's
time for some more advertising here
everybody
um
here we go e-voice
e-voice if you're an entrepreneur and a
customer calls do you want him to see do
you want to seem like you're in a
high-rise window view fancy pants office
or do you want them to know you're just
sitting there in your underwear drinking
a high-c
huh it's a no-brainer with e-voice you
can create the appearance of an entire
building sales customer support tech
support you name it everybody will think
you got it give your customers the royal
treatment with e-voice e-voice will
forge your business calls to your home
mobile already number you choose
wherever you are evoice will find you
don't have time to take a call no biggie
it's routed to your voicemail and you
can read it at your convenience as an
email e-voice not only gives you an edge
over your competitors it takes away the
edge the big companies have over you
right now it's immediately a level
playing field thank god for evoice you
could try it right now for free for 30
days go to evoice.com or just go to the
podcast page at billboard.com and click
on the e-voice banner and last but
certainly not least
hitting clean up legal zoom everybody
a lot of pride comes along with starting
your dream business but think about the
stress you'll feel if you don't take the
right steps to legally protect your
business and personal assets from the
beginning that's why i yours truly
recommend legalzoom.com during the past
12 years over a million business owners
have trusted legalzoom to help start
their businesses legalzoom will save you
a lot of time and a pile of money on
startup costs plus they'll provide
solutions to help you run a successful
business legalzoom can help provide
self-help services at your specific
direction or connect you with an
attorney but they are not repeat not a
law firm just go to legalzoom.com today
and see what's right for you form an llc
get a dba incorporate or form a
nonprofit all starting at just 99 bucks
plus you'll save even more when you
enter my last name bur b-u-r-r in the
referral box at checkout that's
legalzoom.com promo code burr one more
time legalzoom.com promo code burr oh i
lied there's one more
hang in there hang in there
all right
so you know to start your business you
know how to watch tv you know how to
shave you know how to protect your
business what's the last thing you need
to know how to do you need to know how
to go to the post office in 2013
stamps.com everyone there are over 8
million small businesses out there many
of them are wasting time going to the
post office for their mailing and
shipping what they don't know
there's a much better way what is it
stamps.com stamps.com brings all the
services of the post office right to
your fingertips use your own computer
and printer to get official us postage
for any legal for any letter or package
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
automatically calculates the exact
postage for any class of mail it's so
easy to use and convenient even a [ __ ]
like me has been able to do it you'll
never waste time again going to the post
office you won't even need to lease one
of those expensive postage meters i use
stance.com to send out all my dvds my
t-shirts whatever crap you see me
whoring myself out with at the end of my
shows stamps.com got it there never had
a problem right now use my last name
burr burr for this special offer no risk
trial plus 110 bonus offer that includes
the digital scale and up to 55 free
postage don't wait go to stance.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bar b-u-r-r that stamp
stamps.com enter bur
all right
that'll be enough of that
closing that window
uh and we're back to the podcast with
the next another provocative one
crazy [ __ ]
roll out those lazy crazy hazy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
last night i got laid while breaking bad
was playing in the background for my
computer
okay well thank vince gilligan
that ain't me
now i had a little trouble keeping the
guy up during the act even though
she had the ass i would kill for to see
again
so while she was giving me head which
was awesome by the way i look up and
what do i see on the tv billy the
freckled face [ __ ] shows up in a truck
this is a true story by the way i
remember that that's when we we shot
that one in uh santa fe
we shot that one in santa fe when we
robbed the uh rob the train i'm not
gonna say anything else because
everybody
i just started the series
uh i must say i couldn't decide between
keep watching the scene because i hadn't
seen you acting before or enjoying the
[ __ ]
well dude have you ever heard a hit and
pause
this guy's like [ __ ] easy he loves i
thought i loved breaking bad this guy
loves it he says the whole situation was
really awkward because i was imagining
you saying stuff like dude why are you
watching tv while getting a [ __ ]
what are you a fig uh he goes i actually
started laughing not thinking about how
uncomfortable that would make her the
poor girl oh no i was struggling to keep
it up while hearing you in my head going
this guy's a [ __ ]
that's my joke making fun of people who
are homophobic by the way just to
clarify it before i have to apologize to
an overweight blogger on television
uh the remote control was not in my
reach so i had to watch the camera
alternating between
two redheaded [ __ ]
heisenberg an old billy redface
heisenberg's not a red hat he had a
shaved head
you talking about jesse plemons
i don't [ __ ] know he said anyways
thanks for ruining a great blow job you
[ __ ] i'll see you in sweden in december
uh
hey my apologies sir but you guys you
know
i know that you you're way over there in
sweden but i would think that you that
that you guys have remote you know you
have remote controls and you have pause
buttons i've been there
you know
that's really weird sir that made me
uncomfortable with myself
getting a [ __ ] in sweden jesus christ
it was probably some
chick that'd be a [ __ ] 11 over here
and to you guys it's just another uh
just another chick from [ __ ]
stockholm right
um i always mention that whenever i go
over there
when you're in stockholm the city of
stockholm it's just it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
uh
not saying there aren't some regular
looking people but just the percentage
of really good looking people
is uh you know
i i i felt like a [ __ ] when i was
over there like i really need to like i
should have like a hump limping down the
[ __ ] street
um
so anyways dude shake it off and uh
i hope that girl didn't hear you
laughing while she was blowing you
because that could really uh affect her
confidence so make sure you she knows
why you were laughing
all right and just say hey i'm not gonna
watch tv this time and then she'll go to
blow you again and then just the sheer
quietness in the room is gonna make you
start thinking about my dumb face again
you're gonna laugh again you have an
issue sir
uh all right the upper decker
dear state bill i'll get to the point
asap my boss booked me a hotel without a
fridge
when i go to got to the hotel they told
me their computers showed up showed that
the fridge fridges rooms had not been
cleaned
i asked could you just bump me up to one
with the fridge then they responded with
the polite no
they then sent a guy to check if any
other those rooms were cleaned the
fridges fridgeless rooms
they told me
one of them was which i figured means
it had been cleaned
i took the room
i had four strong beers
dog fish head
90-minute ipa i don't know what that
means i know ipas have more alcohol but
i don't know what 90 minute means he
said then anyways he says that i went to
take a shower
i noticed that there was no soap which
means no one fixed the room
that dude who checked must have just
made the bed to top it off the toilet is
not working
[ __ ] would not flush
so
i took an upper decker inside the top
part of the toilet my question is am i
an [ __ ]
p.s this happened 20 minutes ago still
drunk love you work are you an [ __ ]
absolutely
absolutely you're an [ __ ] because
the person who manages that hotel is not
the person who has to clean out the
toilet
and uh
all you're going to do is just [ __ ] over
the person who's got to clean it up yeah
you should have done that [ __ ] come on
man
come on
you know the mature thing to do is you
pick up the phone and you say yeah i
said that this room was ready it's not
ready
there's no soap in here this hasn't
basically the bed has been made the
toilet's not working
that's what you do
you know you don't take a [ __ ] in the
top part of the [ __ ] toilet all right
shame on you i'm disappointed in you you
know better than that i'll give you a
little bit of a slap dude four beers in
you already did that thank god you
didn't have eight
you know you probably would have [ __ ] in
the hall
um wrap up okay that's it people that's
the podcast here
okay
that's the end
see i did all right i did all right i
got myself a nice hour and five minutes
here that's a decent sized podcast oh it
was adorable little podcast listen now
that the show's over don't forget to
sign up for your free trial of hulu plus
hulu plus lets you binge on thousands of
hit shows anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast get an extended free trial of
hulu plus when you go to the podcast
page at billboard.com and click the hulu
plus banner or go to huluplus.com bill
that's huluplus.com bill uh real quick
my next big gigs coming up
is uh what is it november
7th 8th and 9th
three of the biggest gigs
i've had up until this day
um
i'm going to be at constitution hall in
washington dc
i'm going to be in
the beacon theater in new york city and
then i'm gonna be in upper darby
pennsylvania
those dates are november 7th 8th and 9th
and as always i'm going to have the
lovely paul versi opening for me uh
that's a thursday friday and saturday
most of those the first show was sold
out i think there's just one show
in dc but there's two in new york and
two in uh
philly so the first shows i believe are
both sold out and the second one is
going fast so once again thank you to
everybody who uh
has bought up the tickets and um
i'm coming with the best hour that i've
written that's what i like to think and
the weekend after that i'll be in uh
deadwood south dakota the billy red
state make updates the last three
deadwood south dakota on the 15th tulsa
oklahoma brady theater tom brady
november 16th and the orpheum theater
wichita kansas november 17th oh really
quickly by the way the uh
broncos won again
i got to tell you though i'm seeing a
flaw in that team as great as they look
bronco fans i want to hear from you i'm
not being a dick
but they're looking like that classic
regular season team
that scores a zillion points but lets up
half a zillion
and i found that those teams tend to
lose in the playoffs playoffs
the san diego air corial chargers the
dan marino dolphins
the [ __ ] greatest show on turf rams
the year we beat him the year the giants
beat the [ __ ] undefeated patriots
um
that [ __ ] catches up with you because
when you go to the playoffs you're going
to be playing teams with great defense
and when they
slice your offense in half
but your defense can't step it up all of
a sudden you got a close game and next
thing you know you lose 20 to 17 you're
like what the [ __ ] happened we scored 9
million points this season all right
been there as a fan what do you think
we're taking phone calls right now
uh that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you
next week